Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the 1970s and 1980s, I adored the World Cup. I zealously collected the Panini stickers, painstakingly circled the fixtures in my parents' copy of the Radio Times, and watched goggle-eyed as Zico, Socrates and Maradona pirouetted across our television screen. Sadly, today it is simply impossible to look forward to Brazil's carnival of football with the same innocent enthusiasm. The greatest sporting exhibition on the planet has become a bloated monstrosity. Far from embodying the Corinthian virtues of athletic excellence and fair play,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com，并加入在20世纪70和80年代，我曾无比痴迷世界杯。我狂热地收集帕尼尼球星贴纸，煞费苦心地在我父母买的《广播时报》上圈出比赛赛程，然后瞪大眼睛看着济科、苏格拉底和马拉多纳在我们的电视屏幕上轻盈地盘带。遗憾的是，如今要想带着同样单纯的热情去期盼巴西的足球狂欢，简直是不可能的。地球上最伟大的体育盛会已经变成了一个臃肿的庞然大物。世界杯远没有体现出竞技卓越和公平竞赛的科林顿美德，
the World Cup has become synonymous with corporate greed, institutional corruption, and the widening gulf between the international super-rich and the downtrodden masses. That, Dominic Sandbrook, was a top historian harrumphing in the Daily Mail before the World Cup in Brazil in 2014. And the top historian was, of course, yourself. It was. Beautiful prose, Tom. Not just powerful, but beautifully written, I think. Very, very thought-provoking. Our guest is laughing scornfully, I will say. Dominic, we finished our sweep through the World Cup in in our last episode in argentina in 1978
世界杯已经成了企业贪婪、体制腐败，以及国际超级富豪与受压迫大众之间日益扩大的鸿沟的代名词。多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，那是2014年巴西世界杯前夕，《每日邮报》上一位顶级历史学家的严厉斥责。而这位顶级历史学家，当然就是你本人。没错。写得真好，汤姆。不仅充满力量，而且文笔优美，我觉得。非常非常发人深省。我们的嘉宾正在轻蔑地大笑，我得说。多米尼克，我们在上一集关于1978年阿根廷世界杯的节目中结束了对世界杯的回顾
and you could say that that there was a lot of corporate greed there there was certainly quite a lot of institutional corruption and um and and you know they the argentine government were busing shanty people out to shanty towns but we know where they weren't playing fixtures so plus a change basically isn't it between brazil and qatar today i mean absolutely right anything changed much when you when you look at the two episodes we have already done um it's obvious that the world cup has been associated from the very beginning with state building with nationalism with money obviously because football has always been associated with money um and with politics so when people, let's keep politics out of sports,
你可以说那里存在大量的企业贪婪，当然也有相当多的体制腐败，而且你知道，阿根廷政府把平民赶到贫民窟去，但我们知道他们没有在比赛，所以基本上就是换汤不换药，对吧，在今天的巴西和卡塔尔之间？我的意思是，完全正确。当你回顾我们已经做过的这两期节目时，有什么重大变化吗？很明显，世界杯从一开始就与国家建设、民族主义、金钱（显然如此，因为足球一直与金钱息息相关）以及政治联系在一起。所以当人们说“让我们把政治排除在体育之外”时，
politics has never been out of the World Cup. But I think it's certainly true, I would say, that in the last, let's say, 30 years or so, the sort of corporate stranglehold over the World Cup has been stronger and stronger. The sense of it being this sort of, there was a slight hint of innocence, wasn't there, about those 1930s?
政治从来没有离开过世界杯。但我认为这当然是真的，我想说的是，在过去，比方说大约30年里，世界杯受到的企业资本的铁腕控制越来越强。那种感觉，它有某种，在20世纪30年代那种氛围中，是不是有一丝纯真？
Yeah, a bit. Certainly 1930, the very first one apart from Mussolini not the bits from Mussolini um but yeah it's a it's a really interesting question about how this this 1920s 1930s products the world cup um where it sees itself in the 21st century and is it just a vehicle for corporate investment and for dictators and so on but I think what you would also say is that it has grown in significance even greater than it was, say, in the 60s or 70s. And historians, I guess, in 100 years' time looking back at this period will see the World Cup as an absolutely central part of making sense of the geopolitics
是的，有一点。当然是1930年，除了墨索里尼之外的第一届世界杯——虽然不是墨索里尼那些部分——但对，这是一个非常有趣的问题，关于这个20世纪20年代、30年代的产品——世界杯，它在21世纪如何看待自己？它仅仅是企业投资和独裁者等的工具吗？但我认为你也会说，它的重要性甚至比60年代或70年代还要大。我想，100年后的历史学家回看这段时期时，会把世界杯视为理解这一时期地缘政治的绝对核心部分。
of this period. And I think that when you're studying a kind of a major aspect of history, all the way through the episodes we've done, we've been hamstrung by our inability to actually have figures from the period of history that we're discussing actually on the show. So when we did the- Pele didn't join us, sadly. Well, but when we did the Battle of Trafalgar, we didn't have Nelson. We did the conquest of Alexander. He couldn't turn up. But for this, we're going into the 80s, the 90s, the 21st century World Cup. We have a top figure from history on our show, do we not?
而且我认为，当你研究某种重大历史事件时，在我们做过的所有节目中，我们都受到一个限制，那就是我们无法将所讨论的历史时期的实际人物请到节目中来。所以当我们做——贝利没有加入我们，遗憾的是。嗯，但当我们做特拉法加海战时，我们没有尼尔森。我们做亚历山大征服时，他没能出席。但对于这一期，我们要进入80年代、90年代、21世纪的世界杯，我们请到了历史上的一位重量级人物来到我们的节目，不是吗？
We do indeed. So for our American Australian listeners, people who are not interested in football, he'll take a tiny bit of introduction. All our British listeners and our European listeners will know him immediately. He was born in 1960. He's from Leicester. He's the face of crisps, or as Americans would say, chips. So that will give his identity away straight away. He was the top scorer in the 1986 World Cup, won the Golden Boot. He went on to captain his country, to captain England.
确实如此。所以对于我们的美国和澳大利亚听众，也就是对足球不感兴趣的人，他需要一点点介绍。我们所有的英国听众和欧洲听众都会立刻认出他。他出生于1960年。他来自莱斯特。他是薯片的代言人，或者美国人所说的“chips”。这就会直接暴露他的身份。他是1986年世界杯的头号射手，荣膺金靴奖。他后来成为了国家队队长，成为了英格兰队的队长。
And ever since retiring, he has been really the media face of football, not just in England, I think, but one of the absolutely central sort of media faces of football around the world. And it is, of course, Gary Lineker. Gary, welcome to the podcast. Thank you. Great to be on. So we're talking about you as a historical figure. That's how old I am now. In the most flattering sense. In the most flattering way. Exactly. Just as we would talk about Alexander the Great or Nelson, as Tom says.
自从退役以来，他一直是足球界的媒体门面，不仅在英国，我认为他也是全世界足球界绝对核心的媒体门面之一。他当然就是加里·莱因克尔。加里，欢迎来到本播客。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。所以我们在谈论你作为历史人物。我现在已经老到这种程度了。以最恭维的方式。以最恭维的方式。没错。正如汤姆所说，就像我们谈论亚历山大大帝或尼尔森一样。
So you're born in 1960 in Leicester. You're from a family of greengrocers, I think. Is that right? Yeah, my dad was a market trader, sold fruit. So do you remember? So you're too young to remember watching England in 1966, I suppose. Sadly, yes. 1970?
所以你于1960年出生在莱斯特。我想你来自一个蔬菜商家庭。是这样吗？是的，我爸爸是个集市商贩，卖水果。所以你还记得吗？所以你太小了，记不清看1966年英格兰队的比赛了吧，我想。遗憾的是，是的。1970年呢？
70 was my first World Cup. I remember that, which was obviously in Mexico. And it was a very colourful my first World Cup. I remember that, which was obviously in Mexico. And it was a very colourful and great World Cup. And one of my first ever memories was England probably playing Brazil in a group stage. And it was the game where Banks pulled off the remarkable save from Pelé's header. He scooped it over the bar. And then latterly in the tournament, which was England got to the quarterfinals
70年是我的第一届世界杯。我记得那届比赛，显然是在墨西哥。那是一届非常多彩——我的第一届世界杯。我记得那届比赛，显然是在墨西哥。那是一届非常多彩且棒极了的世界杯。我最早的记忆之一就是英格兰可能在小组赛中对阵巴西。那是班克斯完成对贝利头球神扑的比赛。他把球托出了横梁。后来在锦标赛中，英格兰进入了四分之一决赛，
and played against West Germany, as it was then, of course. And England would tow up. Now, my dad, who I said was a fruiture, a market trader, worked really hard all hours. But they'd take a day off sometimes and he'd have a every week they would have a card game at the house and my mum kind of hosted and did a bit and they gave her a little few quid every now and again for that and there was like six seven blokes in
并对阵当时所谓的西德队。当时英格兰两球领先。现在，我爸爸，我刚才说过他是个水果商、集市商贩，没日没夜地辛苦工作。但他们有时会放假一天，他每星期都会在家搞一场纸牌游戏，我妈妈负责招待并做点小事，他们每隔一段时间会为此给她一点小钱，家里大约有六七个大老爷们，
the house every monday and they'd go all night all night until they next morning they go to work or whatever and on this and it never stopped for anything but this one night they did stop to watch England play against Germany and we were two up and we're going to thought we're going to win and then Germany came back and won in extra time three two and I was crying and and I remember my dad and amongst others, Engelbert Humperdinck was one of the players playing cards in my house. Engelbert Humperdinck? Yeah, he used to come around.
每个星期一都在家里聚会，他们通宵达旦，一直玩到第二天早晨去上班什么的，而且从不为任何事情中断。但唯独这一晚，他们停下来看英格兰对阵德国的比赛，我们当时两球领先，我们心想我们要赢了，然后德国队卷土重来，在加时赛中以3比2取胜。我当时哭了，我记得我爸爸，还有其他人，恩格尔伯特·汉普丁克（Engelbert Humperdinck）当时也在我家打牌。恩格尔伯特·汉普丁克？对，他以前经常来。
I know it's bizarre. Jerry Dorsey, as he was known back then, but Engel, as he was known to everyone in our house. So he came around and then I was in tears, floods of tears with England losing because I was only, what, nine years old and they just carried, they just went, right, let's get back and play cards then. And they started and carried on all night. I think it didn't happen. Did Engelbert give a song to cheer you up?
我知道这很离奇。他当时叫杰里·多西（Jerry Dorsey），但在我们家大家都叫他恩格尔。他经常来串门，然后我当时泪流满面，因为英格兰输了，因为我当时才——什么，九岁大，他们只是继续，他们只是说：“好吧，那我们回去继续打牌吧。”然后他们就开始了，通宵达旦地玩。我想这没发生。恩格尔伯特有没有唱歌来哄你开心？
I don't think he probably did. Oh, that's disappointing. Wow. That was unexpected. Yes. So we've done 1978. So the next World Cup uh world cup is in spain in 1982 and obviously geopolitics are a massive factor in that for britain and for argentina because dominic is what's the state
我想他大概没有。哦，真令人失望。哇。这真没想到。是的。所以我们讲到了1978年。所以下一届世界杯——世界杯是在1982年的西班牙举行，显然地缘政治对英国和阿根廷来说是一个巨大的影响因素，因为多米尼克，福克兰群岛的局势
of play in the falklands as the world cup goes on clans uh there was some talk before the tournament um of should the brit British teams pull out? So that's England, Scotland and Northern Ireland. Should Argentina pull out because they're fighting this war? Didn't Jimmy Greaves say that they should have a home nations tournament and the money should go to servicemen? Jimmy Greaves, so for those people who don't know, who was a former striker, brilliant striker,
随着世界杯的进行是怎样的？群岛——在锦标赛开始前有一些讨论，英国球队应该退赛吗？也就是英格兰、苏格兰和北爱尔兰。阿根廷应该退赛吗，因为他们在打这场战争？吉米·格里夫斯是不是说过，他们应该举办一个本土国家锦标赛，奖金应该归军人所有？吉米·格里夫斯，对那些不了解的人来说，他曾是一名出色的前锋，极其优秀的前锋，
but had become a pundit in the 1980s. He was no stranger to outlandish suggestions on TV, but they didn't pull out obviously. And the, and the war ended, I think the day after the tournament started. Um, the other thing is that the draw had,
但在20世纪80年代成为了一名足球专家（评论员）。他在电视上发表离奇言论并不新鲜，但他们显然没有退赛。而且，那场战争在锦标赛开始后的第二天就结束了。另一件事是，抽签方式
I, they had one of those incredibly complicated draws that they had at times. It was little boys, wasn't it? With sort of, but they also, they had a series of groups. So you were in one group, then you were in another group. Yeah. There was a double With little boys, wasn't it? But they also had a series of groups. So you were in one group, then you were in another group.
我，他们当时采用了那种极其复杂的抽签方式。是由小男孩来抽，对吧？带有一种，但他们也有一系列的小组。所以你在一个小组，然后你在另一个小组。对。有一个双重——是由小男孩来抽，对吧？但他们也有一系列的小组。所以你在一个小组，然后你在另一个小组。
Yeah, there was a double group stage then, wasn't there? Going all the way down the tournament because England got to the second group stage and then they didn't lose, but they also didn't score. Didn't score, yeah. And it was kind of a bizarre concept that going from one group stage and then into another group stage to get the two
对，当时有双小组赛阶段，对吧？一直延续到锦标赛的末段，因为英格兰进入了第二个小组赛阶段，然后他们没有输球，但他们也没有进球。没有进球，对吧。这是一个相当离奇的概念，从一个小组赛进入另一个小组赛来决出两个
finalists. But what that meant was we weren't we we we didn't play argentina that would be there was there was it would be very unlikely that we would was that gerrymandered i don't think so i don't i don't think it was true i mean i think the draws there's often been suggestions about draws being gerrymandered to favor the hosts but i don't't think this one was. I might be wrong. I mean, there's always conspiracy theories about all World Cup draws. They are. The hot balls in the pot. Are they hot balls, Gary?
决赛选手。但这意味着我们没有——我们没有跟阿根廷踢，那将会有——极不可能我们会遇到。那是被操纵了吗？我不这么认为。我不——我不认为那是真的。我的意思是，我认为关于抽签偏袒东道主的说法经常出现，但我认为这次没有。我也许错了。我的意思是，关于所有世界杯抽签总是有阴谋论。确实如此。罐子里的热球。加里，那是热球吗？
Well, not from my experience. They're all pretty cold. Right. That's good to know. I've done the odd draw in my time. So, Gary, you had started as a professional footballer by 1982, hadn't you? Playing for Leicester.
嗯，根据我的经验不是。它们都挺冷的。好吧。那就好。我经历过不少次抽签。所以，加里，到1982年你已经开始职业足球生涯了，对吧？效力于莱斯特城。
Yeah, I was playing for Leicester. I was kind of a slow developer. I didn't break into the England team until I was in my mid-20s, 24, 25. Yeah, 84 you started playing for England. 84 was, yeah, my debut, which I came on at Hampden Park against Scotland. Came on for Glenn Hoddle in the last 10 minutes. And then I didn't really play again until probably 85, really and then I started scoring and then the world cup so as a player I mean for those people many many listeners who don't know much about football and don't know don't probably are not
是的，我在莱斯特城效力。我算是一个大器晚成的人。直到我二十多岁中期，24、25岁时，我才入选英格兰队。对，84年你开始为英格兰队效力。84年是，是的，我的处子秀，当时我在汉普登公园对阵苏格兰替补登场。在最后10分钟替下格伦·霍德尔。然后我直到大概85年才真正再次上场，从那以后我开始进球，然后就是世界杯。所以作为一名球员，我的意思是，对那些对足球了解不多、可能对足球没有投入太大热情的许多听众来说，世界杯对你作为一名职业球员来说有多重要？它是全部、是终极梦想，还是仅仅是另一场——
massively invested in football how much does the world cup loom for you genuinely as a professional when it has is it the be all and end all is it this dream or is it just another no no it's no it's huge it's it's it's the biggest stage you can possibly play on as a footballer um you could argue whether it's the best competition um to play now because the champions league is so incredibly strong and club football often they're probably better sides overall but for a player for an individual it's it's it's the pinnacle to represent first your country and then secondly your country at a world cup and it it really is um incredibly special and it is all or also to this day i think players even you know with the money they earn it doesn't matter representing your country um genuinely does make you feel
不，不，不，它太重要了。这是你作为足球运动员所能踢的最大舞台。你可以争论它是不是踢起来最好的比赛，因为欧冠联赛的水平太不可思议了，俱乐部足球总体来说可能往往有更好的球队。但对一个球员、一个个人来说，这是巅峰——首先代表你的国家，其次是在世界杯上代表你的国家。它确实——极其特别，而且直到今天，我认为球员们——即使考虑到他们赚的钱——代表国家参赛，这无关金钱，确实会让你感到
incredibly proud so just to jump in that thing about representing your country genuinely does make you feel incredibly proud. So just to jump in, that thing about representing your country, so the thing that often annoys fans is they'll see of a club team, is they'll say the player will kiss the badge, give everything for their Huddersfield town or whatever, and then what do you know, a week later he's moved to Luton and he's kissing that badge too. So there's a degree of, you could say there's a degree of cynicism.
无比自豪。所以插一句，关于代表国家参赛这件事——常常让球迷感到恼火的是，他们会看到一个效力于某家俱乐部的球员会亲吻队徽，为他们的哈德斯菲尔德镇或其他什么球队拼尽全力，然后你知道吗，一周后他转会去了卢顿，他也同样在亲吻那个队徽。所以某种程度上，你可以说存在一定程度的愤世嫉俗。
But playing for your country, when you're singing the anthem, all that stuff, I mean, does it really, are people cynical about that behind the scenes? I don't think so. I don't think, sometimes you'll get, you know, when the team's not playing very well, and particularly in a tournament like that, you'll often get the mud thrown at you for not trying
但为国效力，当你唱国歌时，所有这些，我是说，这真的——幕后大家对此感到愤世嫉俗吗？我不这么认为。我不认为，有时你会遇到，你知道，当球队踢得不是很好时，特别是在这样的锦标赛中，你经常会因为不努力而受到指责，
and they're not trying, they're not competing hard enough and it's never that. Sometimes it can be that you care too much and the pressure becomes too much for some players. But generally, every player gives everything to be in this tournament and it's one of those, particularly the World Cup we've got coming up now is that we're playing right up to the World Cup. So loads of players are getting injured last minute and missing out, which is a real shame.
说他们不努力，竞争不够拼，但从来都不是这样的。有时可能是因为你在乎得太多，压力对某些球员来说变得太大了。但总体来说，每个球员都倾尽全力来参加这项锦标赛，这也是其中之一，特别是我们即将迎来世界杯时，我们是一直踢到世界杯开赛前的。所以很多球员在最后一刻受伤并缺席，这真是太遗憾了。
So, yes, it's it. I mean, it sounds a bit pathetic, but, you know, to say that it's so important, but it genuinely, genuinely does matter. And it's it's. I do think also part of that is that it is this kind of regular every four years and each World Cup is remembered and commemorated. So you know that if you pull in a brilliant performance, you will be a part of this folklore. You'll become part of it. It's really the best opportunity you have to become internationally significant? Absolutely. I mean, take my own personal situation. When I went, my first World Cup that I played
所以，是的，它确实。我的意思是，这听起来有点可悲，你知道，说它如此重要，但它真真切切非常重要。而且我认为——我也认为其中的一部分原因是，它是一种每四年举行一次的规律赛事，每届世界杯都会被铭记和纪念。所以你知道，如果你奉献出精彩的表现，你就会成为这种民间传说的一部分。你会成为其中的一部分。这真的是你获得国际影响力的最佳机会，对吧？绝对的。我的意思是，拿我个人的情况来说。当我去的——我踢的第一届世界杯
in was 86 in Mexico. And that transformed my life. You know, I went into it as a player that was just breaking through, had a couple of good seasons, you know, won
是1986年的墨西哥。那改变了我的生活。你知道，我参赛时是一名刚刚崭露头角的球员，有过几个出色的赛季，你知道，在英格兰为莱斯特和埃弗顿赢得
the Golden Boot in England for Leicester and then Everton. And then I went to the World Cup and I was known back in England, you know, but then I played in the World Cup and I finished top score in the competition, won the Golden Boot and life changed. Suddenly I was on a plane, I was on my way to Barcelona to sign and play for them for three years. So it is a thing that can launch your career in many ways,
了金靴奖。然后我去了世界杯，在英格兰我已经是小有名气的了，但接着我参加了世界杯，并在赛事中成为头号射手，赢得了金靴奖，人生改变了。突然间我坐上了飞机，前往巴塞罗那签约并在那里效力三年。所以这在很多方面都能开启你的职业生涯，
and it certainly did mine. Just that thing about going to Mexico. I mean, for people of certainly my age and Tom's age, Mexico feels like the sort of the canonical place where you have to have World Cups because 1970 was in Mexico, the Pele World Cup, then the Maradona and Lineker World Cup. I think just the Maradona and Lineker World Cup in 1986. I think just the Maradona World Cup.
我的职业生涯确实就是这样开始的。说到去墨西哥这件事。我的意思是，对于肯定像我和汤姆这个年纪的人来说，墨西哥感觉就像那种正统的地方，你必须在那里举办世界杯，因为1970年是在墨西哥举办的贝利世界杯，然后是马拉多纳和莱因克尔世界杯。我认为只有1986年的马拉多纳和莱因克尔世界杯。我认为只有马拉多纳世界杯。
Well, it's good to butter up the guests, isn't it, Tom? Absolutely. So Mexico, but somebody from, as you say, from Leicester, the market trading background, all that stuff, to go to Mexico, which basically British people didn't go to, I mean, were you just so much in the football bubble that you didn't kind of notice? Or was it as mad and outlandish as it kind of sounds? It was really, but at the time, as you quite rightly say,
好吧，讨好嘉宾总没错，对吧，汤姆？绝对的。所以墨西哥，但作为一个正如你所说来自莱斯特、有着集市商贩背景等等经历的人，去到墨西哥——英国人基本上不会去的地方，我是说，你当时是不是完全深陷足球泡沫之中，以至于没有注意到？还是说它跟听起来一样疯狂而离奇？它真的很疯狂，但当时，正如你非常正确地指出的，
you are in a bubble. And we did go there the year before to compete in a little mini tournament just to try and get a feel acclimatize, that sort of thing. And obviously, you know, Mexico at that stage, I mean, I've watched these series of narcos, you know, and it's like, I had no idea that was going on, that kind of stuff. You know, you have mass killings and the drug wars and the cartels and all this stuff was in its height at that particular point.
你身处一个泡沫之中。我们在前一年确实去那里参加了一个小型迷你锦标赛，只是为了试着感受一下环境、适应气候之类的。显而易见，当时的墨西哥——我的意思是，我看过《毒枭》这一系列电视剧，你知道，我就像，我完全不知道当时正在发生那种事，那种状况。你知道，那里有大规模谋杀、毒品战争、贩毒集团，所有这些都在那个特定时期达到顶峰。
And I used to wonder, I remember when we were there, I wondered why we had this amazing kind of security details with outriding bikes and massive guns driving around with us everywhere we went. When I saw that series, it made sense. Well, because I guess the world then was less globalised, so it was much less connected. Countries like Mexico, if you're European, were more foreign, I guess. Yeah so it was much less connected it countries like mexico if you're european were more foreign i guess yeah it was it um i remember though it was i mean it was a beautiful place um
我过去常常纳闷，我记得我们在那里的时候，我纳闷为什么我们有如此惊人的安全保卫细节，有骑摩托开道的人，还有带着重型武器的车子载着我们去到任何地方。当我看了那部剧后，这一切就说得通了。嗯，因为我猜那时的世界没有那么全球化，所以联系没有那么紧密。像墨西哥这样的国家，如果你是欧洲人，会觉得更加陌生，我猜。对，所以联系没有那么紧密，像墨西哥这样的国家，如果你是欧洲人，会觉得更加陌生，我猜。对，它——我记得尽管如此，它——我的意思是，那是一个美丽的地方，
and we had to climatize and it's because of a lot of mexico's quite high like altitude mexico city for example where we ended up playing last 16 in the quarterfinal. Prior to that, though, we had to play in Monterey, which was a lot lower, but it was incredibly hot. We played three games there in the daytime. I think two of the games were at midday and one at four o'clock, or it might have been the other way around. But we were playing in 40-odd degrees centigrade. And it was, you know, nowadays they would, I don't know whether they'd even allow that.
而且我们必须适应气候，因为墨西哥有很多地方海拔很高，比如墨西哥城，我们最后是在那里踢十六分之一决赛和四分之一决赛。不过在此之前，我们必须在蒙特雷踢球，那里的海拔低得多，但天气热得难以置信。我们在那里白天踢了三场比赛。我想其中两场比赛是在正午进行的，一场在四点钟，或者可能正好相反。但我们是在四十多摄氏度的高温下踢球。而且，你知道，现在他们会——我不知道他们是否甚至允许那样做。
It'd be too dangerous but um it was and we so we had to acclimatize and we went we went before we went to colorado for altitude training etc but we also had to train for the extreme heat and i remember we used to bobby robson decided that we should all train in a steam room so we were doing all press ups and jump squats and all these things in a steam room to get used to playing in that heat. And you were only allowed one call a week home. Is that true? Well, yeah, obviously no mobile phones back then. And, you know, sometimes we discuss the boredom of players pre-World Cup
那太危险了，但是——而且我们必须适应气候，我们在去科罗拉多进行高原训练等之前就去了。但我们还得为极端高温进行训练，我记得我们曾经——博比·罗布森决定我们都应该在蒸汽房里训练，所以我们在蒸汽房里做俯卧撑、跳蹲和所有这些动作，来适应那种高温下的比赛。每周你只被允许给家里打一个电话。是真的吗？嗯，是的，当时显然没有手机。而且，你知道，有时我们会讨论球员在世界杯前夕度过几周集训时的无聊感，
when you spend a few weeks together before the actual thing starts. So you've got to keep yourself entertained. But yeah, there were no mobile phones, no computer games, no laptops, no any, you know, there's very little to do. So you had to make a bit of your own entertainment and also getting any kind of phone.
在真正开赛前几周大家呆在一起。所以你得自娱自乐。但对，当时没有手机，没有电子游戏，没有笔记本电脑，没有任何，你知道，可做的事情非常少。所以你必须自己找点乐子，而且想打任何电话——
We were allowed one phone call home a week. And the interesting thing was just before the World Cup, because I'd done really well with Everton, there was a little bit of interest from Barcelona. And I had a conversation with my agent before I went. And I said, right, I'm going to the World Cup. I don't want any distraction. He went, that's absolutely right.
我们每周被允许给家里打一次电话。有趣的是，就在世界杯开幕前，因为我在埃弗顿表现非常出色，巴塞罗那对我产生了一点兴趣。我在去之前跟我的经纪人谈过。我说：“好吧，我要去踢世界杯了。我不想受到任何干扰。”他说：“完全正确。
Totally understand. So we get through to the quarterfinal. We beat Paraguay and I'd scored three against Poland. I scored two against Paraguay. And then we now got to play against Argentina in the quarterfinals. And we're all sitting in the room and someone comes in and says, there's a phone call for you at reception. And I was like, oh my God, a phone call.
完全理解。”所以我们闯入了四分之一决赛。我们击败了巴拉圭，我对波兰进了三个球，对巴拉圭进了两个球。然后我们要跟阿根廷在四分之一决赛中交手。我们都坐在房间里，有人进来对我说：“前台有你的电话。”我当时就想：“天哪，有电话。
It's incredible. So I go there and I went, hello. He said, it was my agent, John Holmes. It still looks after me to this day so he said um he said i know we had an agreement that i wouldn't bother you during the world cup he said but situation has arisen and i think it's only right that i call you about it he said i've had barcelona on the phone because i'd obviously just scored a few goals they're quite pretty quiet in the start of the tournament when I was hopeless.
太不可思议了。”所以我去了那儿，我说：“喂。”他说——那是我的经纪人约翰·霍姆斯（John Holmes），至今仍然照顾着我。所以他说——他说：“我知道我们有个协议，我在世界杯期间不应该打扰你，”他说，“但现在出现了一种情况，我觉得我只有打电话告诉你才对。”他说：“我接到了巴塞罗那的电话，”因为我在锦标赛刚开始时表现平平，当我一无是处时他们保持沉默。
So he said, they've come on and they've said, we want Gary, he's got to sign and he's got to agree to sign now, otherwise it's off. He said, so I felt like I had to tell you. I said, well, I said, I can't do that now. Imagine if I signed for Barcelona during the World Cup, I'd be hung drawn and quartered when I get home.
所以他说：“他们打电话来了，说他们想要加里，他必须签约，而且他必须同意现在签约，否则就算了。”他说：“所以我感觉我不得不告诉你。”我说：“好吧，”我说，“我现在不能这么做。想象一下，如果我在世界杯期间签约巴塞罗那，我回家后会被剥皮抽筋的。
I said, if they want me now, they'll want me at the end of the tournament. So, and he went, that's absolutely the answer I needed to hear, but I wanted to tell you. So yeah, that was my one phone call, which is quite remarkable. I did eventually go to Barcelona. And that's just before the game against Argentina.
”我说：“如果他们现在想要我，他们在锦标赛结束后也会想要我。”然后他说：“这绝对是我需要听到的答案，但我还是想告诉你。”所以，是的，那是我的唯一一通电话，这相当非凡。我最终确实去了巴塞罗那。那是对阵阿根廷的比赛前夕。
A couple of days before, yeah. So the famous quarterfinal against Argentina, how much were you and the team aware of the context that was provided both by footballing history and by political history? We were made very aware because every single press conference, every single interview that we were doing, we were asked about the Falklands conflict. Will that affect the game?
比赛前几天，是的。所以对阵阿根廷的那场著名的四分之一决赛，你和球队对足球历史和政治历史所提供的背景了解多少？我们对此非常清楚，因为在每一场新闻发布会上，我们做的每一次采访中，我们都被问到关于福克兰群岛冲突的问题。这会影响比赛吗？
Does it make it more important? And everybody, everybody was just trying to play it down. And so were the Argentinians as well. I saw Maradona interviewed before the game. But I think it added to it. And I honestly think, and I was having this conversation with a few friends the other day, I honestly think that that game, the quarterfinal against Argentina, is the most, not necessarily the best, but certainly, I think,
这会让比赛变得更重要吗？每个人——每个人都只是试图淡化它。阿根廷人也是如此。我在赛前看到了对马拉多纳的采访。但我觉得这增添了赛事的氛围。老实说，我——我前几天在和几个朋友谈论这件事时还在想，老实说，我认为那场比赛，对阿根廷的四分之一决赛，是最——不一定是最好的，但肯定，我认为，
the most famous game in the history of football. I mean, people will come and throw other things at me. And I think it was a World Cup quarterfinal. It was just a few years after the war in the Falklands you got the greatest goal probably ever scored yeah and also the most infamous goal ever so just for people who don't know anything about football just explain why it's so famous and and why those two goals are so significant well it was two of the you of the big powers in world football. It was post the war and the game featured Diego Armando Maradona, who was the best footballer on earth by quite some distance at the time. And it was goalless in the first half, wasn't a very good game. And then the second half, the ball gets flicked back by Steve Hodge, who claims to this day that it was a deliberate back pass, but I don't know how, I'm not sure. And Diego Maradona comes up, goes as low as he's going to head it,
是足球史上最著名的比赛。我的意思是，人们会拿其他事情来反驳我。而且这是一场世界杯四分之一决赛。它就发生在福克兰群岛战争几年后，你拥有可能是有史以来最精彩的进球，是的，还有最厚颜无耻的进球。所以对那些对足球一无所知的人来说，请解释一下为什么它如此著名，以及为什么这两个进球如此意义重大。嗯，这是世界足坛两大豪强之间的对决。那是战后进行的，比赛的主角是迭戈·阿曼多·马拉多纳，当时他毫无争议地是地球上最好的足球运动员。上半场双方互交白卷，比赛并不精彩。然后到了下半场，球被史蒂夫·霍奇（Steve Hodge）回顶了一下，他至今坚称那是一个有意的回传，但我不知道怎么说，我不确定。迭戈·马拉多纳冲上来，压低身体准备头球，
and then punches it into the net. Now, the referee didn't see it. The linesman, I think, did, but didn't have the nerve to give it. He's subsequently written a book where he did say he thought he handballed it, but he didn't have the nerve to give the decision. And they led 1-0. And then just a few minutes later, Maradona picks the ball up on the halfway
然后一拳把球打进了网窝。裁判没有看见。边裁我想是看见了，但没有勇气判罚。他后来写过一本书，确实说他当时认为那是手球，但他没有勇气作出那个判罚。他们以1比0领先。然后仅仅几分钟后，马拉多纳在中场线附近拿球，
line, does a wriggle, does a turn, does a twist, beats one, beats two, beats three, beats four, beats five, goes around Peter Shilton and knocks it in the back of the net on a pitch that was like a cabbage patch. So how he did that was, it would justify belief. I've said this many times, but it's the one time in my life
一个假动作，一个转身，一个变向，过了一个，过了两个，过了三个，过了四个，过了五个，绕过彼得·希尔顿（Peter Shilton），把球送进球门后方，而那块场地就像是一片菜地。所以他是怎么做到的，简直令人匪夷所思。我多次说过，这是我一生中唯一一次
where I thought I should probably applaud a goal. I didn't because I'd be given hell at home. And after that, we came back, John Barnes came on, whipped the ball across. I got the goal that no one remembers in that game. Everybody remembers that goal. Yeah, we all remember that. We all remember that. In England they might remember.
觉得我或许应该为一粒进球鼓掌的时刻。我没有鼓掌，因为我在家里会挨惨骂的。在那之后，我们反扑，约翰·巴恩斯（John Barnes）替补上场，将球传中。我打进了那场比赛中没人记得的进球。所有人都记得那个进球。是的，我们都记得。我们都记得。在英格兰可能有人记得。
And then just a couple of minutes before the end of the game, Barnes again gets down the left, crosses the ball in and I think I'm going to score. I head it and from somewhere, I think it was a lot of good chair, the left back for Argentina jumps on, hits the back of his head and goes out.
然后在比赛结束前短短几分钟，巴恩斯再次从左路突破，把球传进禁区，我以为我要进球了。我头球攻门，从某个地方——我想是阿根廷的左后卫胡利奥·奥拉尔蒂科切亚（Julio Olarticoechea），腾空跃起，球打在他的后脑勺上飞出了底线。
And we lost the game. But to have a game that was, A, post a war between two countries, B, in a World Cup and a knockout game in a quarterfinal, to have the best goal ever scored and probably the most impudent goal ever scored, I think it's the most famous game ever. The hand of God. It was brilliant. He not only said that, he said it was a little bit
然后我们输掉了比赛。但是，能够经历这样一场比赛：第一，发生在两个交战国之间的一场战争之后；第二，在世界杯的淘汰赛四分之一决赛中；并且同时拥有有史以来最精彩的进球和可能最无礼的进球，我认为这是史上最著名的比赛。上帝之手。这太精彩了。他不仅这么说，他还说那是
the head of Maradona and a little bit the hand of God. I mean, what a brilliant line to think of at the end of that. And Maradona, I mean, so I would guess even our listeners who despise football will definitely have heard of Maradona.
马拉多纳的一点点头球和上帝的一点点手球。我的意思是，在赛后能想出这么绝妙的一句台词。而马拉多纳——我的意思是，我猜即使是那些鄙视足球的听众也绝对听说过马拉多纳。
I mean, Maradona is one of the, probably the two most famous footballers who ever lived with Pele. And I guess you've met him a lot, haven't you? Because you've interviewed him. You've been to, I think you've been've met him a lot, haven't you? Because you've interviewed him. I think you've been to Argentina to meet him.
我的意思是，马拉多纳是——可能与贝利一起，是生平最著名的两名足球运动员之一。我猜你经常见到他，对吧？因为你采访过他。我想你去过——你经常见到他，对吧？因为你采访过他。我想你去过阿根廷见他。
I did a documentary with him for two or three days in his company. And his life was just extraordinary. I mean, he obviously had his issues with addiction. And we lost him just a couple of years ago, sadly. But he was an amazing individual, hugely charismatic and unbelievably talented. Certainly for your American, he's kind of like the Michael Jordan of football in many ways.
我和他一起拍过纪录片，在他的陪伴下度过了两三天。他的生活简直非同寻常。我的意思是，他显然有他的毒瘾问题。遗憾的是，我们在几年前失去了他。但他是一个了不起的人，极具个人魅力且才华横溢。对你们美国人来说，他在很多方面就像是足球界的迈克尔·乔丹。
But kind of more than that, because to Argentinians, I get the sense that, so he's from the streets. He was that urchin. So he's the sort of the representative he was five foot four but also he'd beaten the anglo-saxon pirates that argentina had always blamed you know going back to the 19th century they'd sort of resented britain and he had he hadn't just beat us with a good goal but he'd outsmarted us with a yeah a bad goal as a way yeah he gets i think that in in Argentina he gets as much credit
但某种程度上比那还要夸张，因为对阿根廷人来说，我有一种感觉，他是从街头走出来的。他是那个顽童。所以他是那种代表人物——他身高只有五英尺四英寸（约1.62米），而且他还击败了阿根廷一直归咎的盎格鲁-萨克逊海盗（追溯到19世纪，他们一直对英国怀有怨恨），而他不仅用一记好球击败了我们，还用一记——不太光彩的进球智胜了我们。他通过这种方式——是的，我认为在阿根廷，他因
for punching the ball in the net because they think that was the ultimate in trickery and skullduggery and I think they
把球一拳打进网里而获得了极高的赞誉，因为他们认为那是诡计和欺诈的极致，而且我认为
they love that aspect of it whereas we here we wouldn't even I wouldn't even think to have done that I mean I could have done that
他们热爱这一面，而在我们这里，我们甚至——我甚至不会想到那样做。老实说，
with that cross at the end to be perfectly honest if I'd known the fellow was coming in I could have punched it in. But it wouldn't cross my mind to do it. We're just too sporting, aren't we, Gary? That's the trouble.
如果我知道那家伙要冲上来，我完全可以用那种方式把球打进去。但这根本不会进入我的脑海。我们只是太有体育精神了，对吧，加里？麻烦就出在这里。
Well, it's the Corinthian spirit, Dominic, that you were talking about. Corinthian spirit never gets you anywhere, does it? Yeah, so you've got knocked out. Exactly. But Maradona also hugely, hugely popular in Naples. He plays in Naples. Oh, well, he played for Naples. He played for Napoli and they won Serie A for the first time ever in their history.
嗯，这就是科林顿精神，多米尼克，你刚才说的那种。科林顿精神可从来没让你获得过什么好处，对吧？对，所以你们被淘汰了。没错。但马拉多纳在那不勒斯也极受欢迎。他在那不勒斯效力。哦，对，他效力于那不勒斯俱乐部。他效力于那不勒斯，他们赢得了队史上第一座意甲冠军。
So there's a shrine to him. I saw a shrine. They've got one of his hairs. Well, when I spent the two or three days with him in Buenos Aires, I went to his home. We had a barbie. And then we went to watch a game. We went to watch Boca Juniors play at the Bombonera. And it was an extraordinary experience though
所以那里有一座他的神龛。我见过一座神龛。他们甚至留着他的一根头发。好吧，当我跟他在布宜诺斯艾利斯度过那两三天时，我去了他家。我们搞了个烧烤。然后我们去看比赛。我们去糖果盒球场看博卡青年队的比赛。那是一次非凡的体验，
it was it was like you know when you you know watch a film you know life of brian for example when they're all following the messiah it was it was like it was like that people came from everywhere and treated him like this god and they're crying at his feet and i'm thinking how can you live like this every day everywhere he goes like, and we went up and he has his own box at the Bombonera where Bocca Juniors play, which is his team. And we go up there and as soon as he stands on it, like a balcony, like a kind of like Caesar looking at his bed and,
尽管——这就好像，你知道当你——看一部电影，比如《布莱恩的一生》，里面所有人都在追随弥赛亚一样，它就是那种感觉。人们从四面八方涌来，把他当成神一样对待，他们在他的脚下哭泣，而我在想：你怎么能每天都过这种生活？他走到哪里都——我们上楼去，他在博卡青年队（也就是他的球队）的主场糖果盒球场拥有自己的包厢。我们走上去，他刚一站在那上面，就像一个阳台上，就像凯萨大帝俯视他的子民一样，
and the whole crowd starts singing and jumping and, and he's leaning over the balcony. He's leaning over so much that his daughter, I remember, was holding him to try to make sure they didn't fall off the edge of the balcony. I mean, he was the most spectacular. And it was mad, really, because I played in an era of, you know, with wonderful players, like Zico and people like Platini.
全场的观众就开始高歌、跳跃，而他探身出阳台。他探身太厉害了，我记得他的女儿一直在拉着他，确保他不会从阳台边缘摔下去。我的意思是，他是最壮观的。这真的很疯狂，因为我踢球的那个年代，有像济科和普拉蒂尼这样出色的球员，
But this fellow was, these fellows were so good, but he was on a completely different level again. He was that good. So he, the next World Cup is 1990 and that's in Italy. So Maradona, again, to an extent is, you know, he's a key figure, isn't he? He's a key figure. But this is a time when the England team is notorious
但这家伙——这些家伙固然很棒，而他完全处于另一个更高的层级。他就是那么厉害。所以他——下一届世界杯是1990年，在意大利举行。所以马拉多纳在某种程度上仍然是一个关键人物，对吧？他是一个关键人物。但这是一个英格兰队因
for being, for hooliganism, troubles with hooliganism, endless calls to bring back the Birch from outraged Tory MPs and so on. And so you, you get kind of get penned in Sardinia, don't you? The, the, the group. We did. That's where the draw put us. I don't know whether it was deliberate to try and stick us on a little island to keep our supporters away. But I mean, obviously, my whole career was played constantly with the backdrop of hooliganism of our England fans,
足球流氓行为而臭名昭著的时期，流氓行为引发的麻烦不断，愤怒的保守党议员等人无休止地呼吁恢复鞭刑等等。所以你们被限制在撒丁岛上，对吧？那支球队。我们确实是。抽签把我们分到了那里。我不知道这是否有意为之，想把我们困在一个小岛上以阻止我们的支持者前往。但显而易见，我的整个职业生涯一直伴随着英格兰球迷的足球流氓行为的背景，
that some of them, not all of them, obviously, in a small percentage, but would go follow the England team anywhere to try and have a fight and cause trouble. And it was pretty grim. You know, there were various trips abroad where I'd witnessed it myself. And it was, you know, I just never really could get my head around it. But the England team in that tournament, you won the good, what was it, the good behaviour award or whatever,
其中一些人，当然不是全部，只是一小部分，会跟着英格兰队去任何地方试图打架和制造麻烦。那相当惨淡。你知道，我曾多次亲自目睹过这种海外之行。而且，你知道，我真的无法理解这种行为。但在那届锦标赛中，英格兰队赢得了——那是什么来着，良好行为奖还是别的什么，
you got a gold star for being the best behaved or something. Yeah, amazing, yeah. That was a small conversation. the good behavior award or whatever you got a gold star for being the best behaved or something. Yeah. Amazing. Yeah. That was a small conversation, but I guess, so the 1990 world cup is the middle-class world cup. Having talked about the hooliganism and it's, it's,
你们因为表现最好而获得了一颗金星什么的。是的，太棒了，是的。那是一个小小的谈话。良好行为奖什么的，你们因为表现最好而获得了一颗金星什么的。是的。太棒了，是的。那是一个小小的谈话，但我猜，1990年世界杯是中产阶级世界杯。在谈论了足球流氓行为之后，它
it's the one where middle-class people start following it. Opera, Pavarotti, all that kind of stuff. In the UK. I think certainly in England, I think it was, it was also almost a watershed moment in many ways. I think it, things that kind of stuff. In the UK, I think, certainly in England, I think it was almost a watershed moment in many ways.
是中产阶级开始关注它的世界杯。歌剧、帕瓦罗蒂，所有这些。在英国。我想肯定在英格兰，我认为这在许多方面也是一个分水岭时刻。我认为——所有这些。在英国，我认为，肯定在英格兰，我认为这几乎是许多方面的一个分水岭时刻。
I think things changed quite a lot. We'd also had Hillsborough, we'd had Heysel in recent times, you know, two terrible tragedies within stadiums. So we were coming also, England clubs were banned from Europe because of what happened at Heysel. So we came from a period, really, of the absolute doldrums for football. It was, you know, hooliganism was rife. Spectators were down.
我认为事情发生了很大的变化。我们当时还经历了希尔斯堡惨案，不久前还发生了海瑟尔惨案，你知道，球场内发生了两起可怕的悲剧。所以我们也经历了一段足球绝对低谷的时期。当时，足球流氓行为猖獗。观众人数下降。
There weren't that many people going to watch football. Stadia were kind of falling to pieces. And then suddenly we had 1990 and people fell in love with football again because we went long into the tournament we had an amazing moment plat scoring um incredible volley in the 120th minute which is the last minute of extra time um to send us through against Belgium then we played Cameroon I got a couple of penalties and we sneaked through in that one then we played Germany and we were unlucky and we ended up losing on a penalty shootout. But it was like people fell in love with football again.
没有多少人去看球。球场都快坍塌了。然后突然间我们迎来了1990年，人们重新爱上了足球，因为我们一路杀入锦标赛深处，我们经历了一些精彩的时刻——普拉蒂尼在第120分钟打进了一记不可思议的凌空抽射，那是加时赛的最后一分钟，帮助我们淘汰了比利时晋级，然后我们踢了喀麦隆，我罚进两个点球，我们惊险过关，接着我们踢德国，我们运气不佳，最终在点球大战中落败。但感觉就像人们重新爱上了足球。
It wasn't just the working class. All of a sudden, you know, we get mobbed in the streets when we came home. And Gazza's tears. Women and young people, Gazza's tears. Gazza's tears. Gazza was obviously given a yellow card. He seconded the tournament in the semi-final against Germany,
不仅仅是工人阶级。突然之间，你知道，当我们回到家时，我们在街上被围得水泄不通。还有加扎的眼泪。妇女和年轻人，加扎的眼泪。加扎的眼泪。加扎显然吃到了一张黄牌，那是他在对阵德国的半决赛中吃到的本届赛事第二张黄牌。
which meant that he would miss the final should we make the final, which obviously we didn't because we lost in the penalty shootout. And there was a moment where I looked at the bench and it became the question I was most asked. You know, what were you saying? And I just kind of gave a look with my eye to Bobby Robson and said, have a word with him. Basically keep an eye on him because Gazza was starting to cry
这意味着他将错过决赛，如果我们能进决赛的话，而我们显然没有，因为我们在点球大战中输了。当时我看着替补席，那一幕成了我被问得最多的问题。你知道的，你当时在说什么？我只是朝博比·罗布森使了个眼色，然后说，去跟他说说。基本上就是看着他点，因为加扎开始哭了
because he knew he wouldn't play in the final if we made it. But he actually rallied and did really well in extra time. So, Gary, that's against Germany. In our last episode, we were talking about the shadow of the Second World War. So when Germany won in 1954 against Hungary, all the press coverage in Britain and France and elsewhere
因为他知道如果我们进了决赛，他也没法上场。但他实际上振作了起来，在加时赛中表现得非常好。所以，加里，那是对阵德国。在上一集里，我们谈到了第二次世界大战的阴影。所以当德国队在1954年战胜匈牙利时，英国、法国和其他地方的所有媒体报道
was about this was the resurgence of the Nazis. Well, Hungary were top in that final. They were indeed. In 1974, also Germany behind against the Dutch. They beat the Dutch. Again, it's the shadow of the war hangs very heavy, particularly for some Dutch players who'd lost family in the war. And then in 90, I mean, certainly from my perspective,
都在说这是纳粹的卷土重来。嗯，匈牙利在那场决赛中一度领先。他们确实领先了。1974年，也是德国落后于荷兰人。他们击败了荷兰人。同样，战争的阴影挥之不去，特别是对一些在战争中失去亲人的荷兰球员而言。然后到了90年，我的意思是，至少从我的角度来看，
having watched it, I remember the huge sort of upsurge of anti-German sentiment in England among people in my generation who had never talked about it before who felt you know the thought that the Germans of all people had beaten us on penalties well we do we do get we do get a little bit obsessed with the Germans in this. But did you feel that at all as players? Let me put it this way. The night before the World Cup semi-final, England against Germany, we had a team meeting. Bobby Robson called a team meeting and it was just before the other
在观看了比赛之后，我记得英国我这一代人中爆发了大规模的的反德情绪，这些人以前从没谈论过这个，他们觉得，竟然是德国人、偏偏是德国人在点球大战中击败了我们，好吧，我们在对德国这件事上确实有点着迷。但作为球员，你们当时有这种感觉吗？我这么说吧。世界杯半决赛前夜，英格兰对阵德国，我们开了一个队会。博比·罗布森召集了一次队会，那正是在另一场
semi-final, which was taking place the night before our game, which was Italy against Maradona's Argentina in Naples, where Maradona ends up scoring a penalty in the shootout and they knock the Italians out in his hometown. Not quite his hometown, but you know what I mean. But we had this team meeting. Now during, as I said earlier, often in tournaments, there's not a lot going on.
半决赛之前。那场半决赛在我们比赛的前一晚举行，是意大利对阵马拉多纳的阿根廷，比赛在那不勒斯进行。马拉多纳在点球大战中罚进点球，他们在他的主场把意大利人淘汰出局。虽然不算完全是他的主场，但你知道我的意思。但我们开了这个队会。现在，正如我刚才所说，在锦标赛期间，通常没有太多事情可做。
It's quite dull. So we try and entertain ourselves. For example, I always used to run a book, like a bookmaker, there's not a lot going on it's quite dull so we try and entertain ourselves um for example i was i always used to run a book like a bookmaker and we did that all the players had bets on the football matches we'd have race nights where our physio used to bring in tapes of race meetings and i knew how to run a book because i did it at leicester race course when i was about 16 17 for a couple of years for a bookie so So I knew how to do that. And my roommate was Peter Shilton. So he helped me do it.
日子挺无聊的。所以我们试着自己找乐子。例如，我以前总是开个盘，就像个博彩公司那样，日子挺无聊的所以我们试着自己找乐子，嗯，例如，我以前总是开个盘，就像个博彩公司那样，我们都这么玩，所有球员都对足球比赛下注，我们还会办赛马之夜，我们的理疗师会带比赛录像带来，我知道怎么开盘，因为我大约16、17岁时在莱斯特赛马场为一个庄家干过两三年，
And we were called Honest Links and Shilts. And we do it all this betting. And on the night before the England-Germany game, we had this meeting. Bobby Robson called it. He was a little bit late as he often was, but he always used to have one of those clipboard, big paper clipboards.
所以我会干这个。我的室友是彼得·希尔顿。所以他帮我一起搞。我们叫“诚实林克斯与希尔茨”。我们搞了所有这些博彩。在英格兰对德国比赛的前夜，我们开了这个会。博比·罗布森召集的。他稍微迟到了一会儿，他经常这样，但他总是拿着那种夹板，大号的纸质夹板。
And before he came, i got the big marker pen and i wrote on it even money he mentions the war so and then i turned then i turned the page back over about the clip so and then bobby robson eventually comes in oh sorry i'm late lads and then he stood at the front and his first words were we beat them in the war and the place was in uproar everyone's clapping he's going what what's going on what's going on and someone said look at the clipboard so he said turn it over he turned over the page and he went linica you bastard so there were some people in your team who are who were very patriotic i mean most famous example i think we're all patriotic. We show it in
在他来之前，我拿了一支粗马克笔在上面写道：“他提到战争的赔率是1比1”，然后我把它翻过来，用夹子夹好，接着博比·罗布森终于进来了：“哦，抱歉我迟到了，小伙子们。”然后他站在最前面，他的第一句话是：“我们在战争中击败了他们。”全场顿时哗然，每个人都在鼓掌，他纳闷地说：“怎么了？怎么了？”有人说：“看夹板。”于是他说：“翻过来。”他把纸翻过去，说道：“林尼卡，你个混蛋。”所以你们队里有些人非常爱国，我的意思是，最著名的例子，我想我们都很爱国。我们以
different ways. Terry Butcher, who literally bled for his country, didn't he? Yeah, I remember playing Yugoslavia in one game. Terry Butcher was
不同的方式表现出来。特里·布彻，他简直为祖国流尽了鲜血，对吧？对，我记得有一次踢南斯拉夫的比赛。特里·布彻是
this, I mean, he's about six foot four, Terry. He's huge, big central defender, frightening bloke. And I remember we played Yugoslavia, we
这样的，我的意思是，特里身高大约六英尺四英寸。他是个身材高大的中后卫，一个吓人的家伙。我记得我们对阵南斯拉夫，
had to get at least a point and we went out, it was a qualifier for the Euros or I think and so we were in the tunnel before the game and in in the middle between the two teams they had this like wire mesh kind of fence bizarre thing and um I'll never forget that Terry Votche went over it and he shook it it was like come on cage tiger and he's like, you could see them shrink on the other side
我们必须至少拿到一分才能出局，那是欧洲杯预选赛还是什么的，所以我们在比赛前的球员通道里，两队中间有那种铁丝网一样的围栏，挺诡异的，嗯，我永远不会忘记特里·布彻走了过去，摇晃着铁丝网，就像在挑衅“来啊，把笼子里的老虎放出来”，他就像是，你能看到对方球员在
of the terrifying movie. But yeah, obviously fiercely patriotic, but do you really think in 1990, young men going out to play in a World Cup were actually bothered
铁丝网的那一边吓得缩了回去，真是个吓人的家伙。但是，是的，显然非常爱国，但你真的认为在1990年，出场参加世界杯的年轻小伙子们真的会在意
about what had happened previously in the war? Although the hooligans were, right? Because the hooligans still sing. Or do you think it's just a performance?
战争中过去发生过的事情吗？虽然足球流氓会在意，对吧？因为足球流氓还在唱歌。还是说你认为这只是一种表演？
I think it's a performance,? I think it's a performance, but I think it, you know, fans do sing songs to this day about various things that they shouldn't be singing about really. So the final is West Germany. And it's the last time that it's West Germany rather than Germany. Because of course the Berlin Wall had come down the year before against
我认为这只是一种表演吗？我认为这是一种表演，但我觉得，你知道的，直到今天，球迷们仍然会唱一些关于各种不该唱的事情的歌曲。所以决赛的对手是西德。这也是最后一次以“西德”而不是“德国”的名义参赛。因为当然，柏林墙在前一年倒塌了。对阵
Argentina. They can't both lose. Who do you want to win? That's a really good question. I actually went to that final to receive the aforementioned remarkably wonderful FIFA Fair Play Award, which I
阿根廷。他们不可能同时输球。你想让谁赢？这是一个非常好的问题。我实际上去了那场决赛，去领取前面提到过的、非常精彩的国际足联公平竞赛奖，我
received with Bobby Robson. So I went to that game. It was the most dire game. But in the end, Germany went through a penalty from Andy Bramer, who took a penalty in the shootout against England with one foot, I think the left, and then in the final
和博比·罗布森一起领了奖。所以我去看了那场比赛。那是最糟糕的一场比赛。但最终，德国队凭借安迪·布雷默罚进的点球赢了。他在对阵英格兰的点球大战中是用一只脚罚进的，我想是左脚，然后在决赛中
took it with his other foot which for a, you know it's quite an imaginable thing to do but they won by one, yeah I didn't really care who won to be honest. Right Okay, I think we should take a break here and when we come back perhaps we could look at some of the uh the kind of the broad themes over the past
用另一脚罚进了，对于一个，你知道的，这真是难以想象的事情，但他们以一球优势获胜。是的，老实说，我并不真正在乎谁赢。好吧，我想我们应该在这里休息一下，当我们回来时，也许我们可以回顾一下过去
30 years in the world cup so increasing globalization uh sinister despots taking over all that kind of stuff so uh we will be back with um the most recent decades of the world cup i'm marina hyde And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
30年世界杯的一些宏观主题，比如日益加剧的全球化、险恶的独裁者上台等等，所以我们将在节目中回顾最近几十年的世界杯，我是玛丽娜·海德，
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestis rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history with our guest gary lineker gary um tom kicked off the very first episode with a brilliantly moving reading from a very popular newspaper by me about the World Cup and corruption and just looking very very broadly at the last few decades before we get into the individual stories do you think the World Cup has sold its soul as it were? Well we've had enormous corruption issues I think the
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦花絮的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番剧并提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com，也就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史至死》，我们的嘉宾是加里·莱因克尔。加里，汤姆在第一集开场时，读了一篇非常受欢迎的报纸上一篇精彩感人的文章，内容关于世界杯和腐败，在深入探讨具体故事之前，非常广泛地回顾一下过去几十年，你觉得世界杯是不是已经出卖了自己的灵魂？嗯，我们遇到了巨大的腐败问题，我认为
tournament itself is still magical I think it's the greatest sporting event of all, personally, but I'm slightly biased, obviously, as a football man. But yes, of course, it's incredibly global these days, incredibly powerful corporate as well, and there's a massive amount of money. Now, where there's a massive amount of money, there's often corruption. Where there's money, there's whatever it is um and so yes we've had that to a great degree um much to the detriment of football my favorite um corrupt figure was chuck blazer oh what he's remarkable bloke who who was the american fifa representative wasn't he? He was about 200 stone.
赛事本身依然充满魔力，就我个人而言，我认为这是最伟大的体育赛事，但我作为一个足球人，显然有点偏心。但当然，如今它极其全球化，其企业化力量也极其强大，并且涉及巨额资金。现在，哪里有巨额资金，哪里往往就有腐败。哪里有钱，哪里就有……不管是什么，所以是的，我们在很大程度上遇到了这种情况，这非常损害足球运动。我最喜欢的腐败人物是查克·布雷泽，哦，他是个了不起的家伙，他是美国国际足联代表，对吧？他大约有200英石重。
I think he ended up getting paid a couple of apartments in New York where he would be in one. But I think it was all paid for by FIFA and stuff. I think he had an apartment. He had a separate apartment for his cats. That's very kind of Roman Emperor, isn't it? It really is. I went to the notorious 2010, what they call the bidding finale in Switzerland when they decided to go with Russia and Qatar as the two bids.
我想他最后得到的报酬是在纽约有两套公寓，他会住在其中一套里。但我想这些全都是国际足联付的钱之类的。我想他有一套公寓，专门用来养他的猫。这非常有罗马皇帝的风范，不是吗？确实如此。我去了臭名昭著的2010年，也就是他们在瑞士所谓的申办决赛，当时他们决定将俄罗斯和卡塔尔定为两个申办国。
I wasn't part of the England bid team. I'd been left out of that. But somebody got wind of the fact that I knew Michel Platini and I played golf with him and thought it might be a good idea if I flew out the night before and came and had a chat with one or two of the committee members of FIFA. I said, what are your country calls? So I went there, but there was already like Prince William
我不是英格兰申办团队的成员。我被排除在外了。但有人风闻我认识米歇尔·普拉蒂尼，还跟他打过高尔夫球，觉得如果我在前一天晚上飞过去，和国际足联的一两个委员会成员聊聊，可能会是个好主意。我说，你们国家的诉求是什么？所以我去了那里，但当时已经有威廉王子、
and David Cameron and David Beckham and all these people. And it was a strange thing. All these committee members were all around this hotel room. You know, it was Chuck Blazer, all these dreadful, some of them were. And we were sat there and I was thinking, where are all the people from the other bidding countries there's no one else here and i we had a burger i sat down with david beckham afterwards as you do and i said to him i said this is a bit odd isn't it there's only us here do you not think this is like already been done and decided um and and
大卫·卡梅伦和大卫·贝克汉姆以及所有人。那是个奇怪的场景。所有这些委员会成员都在这个酒店房间里。你知道的，有查克·布雷泽，所有这些可怕的人，其中一些人是这样的。我们坐在那里，我在想，其他申办国的人都在哪儿？这里没有其他人了。后来我和大卫·贝克汉姆坐在一起吃了一个汉堡，就像你常做的那样，我对他说，这有点奇怪，不是吗？这里只有我们。你不觉得这就像是已经内定和决定好了吗？
so it proved because england didn't even get past the first vote and the way they do it and then it ended up being russia which you know russia had a had a strong bid but and then the remarkable thing came out the hat for the for the 2022 world cup which is where we are now of the name qatar and it was like what and? And that's when, you know, you kind of absolutely knew that there was corruption. So you went, when you were involved in the media, you went to the United States in 94, is that right? I didn't actually.
事实也的确如此，因为英格兰甚至都没能通过第一轮投票，他们的运作方式就是这样，然后结果变成了俄罗斯，你知道的，俄罗斯有一份很强的申办方案，然后令人震惊的事情从帽子里抽出来了，2022年世界杯的举办地——我们现在的这个地方——名字叫卡塔尔，当时的感觉就像是：“什么？”就在那时，你知道的，你绝对可以确定其中存在腐败。所以你去了，当你从事媒体工作时，你在94年去了美国，是这样吗？其实我没有。
I was playing in Japan at the time, at the end of career. And I did a bit of punditry for two weeks but it was from London and all right yeah so they were we did do it around that world cup but I wasn't there so that's the first world cup really where they're clearly trying to kind of evangelize yeah they're trying to take it to somewhere where I mean do you think that's what they should be doing spreading the gospel of football or do you think they should be it should be happening in places where people actually care about football um it's a good question i mean i mean they've got it again in the next world cup sharing it with mexico and canada but no i have no problem with it it going around the world america's a strange one you know people say that you know they're not interested
我当时在职业生涯末期的日本踢球。我做了两周的专家评论员，但那是从伦敦连线的。好吧，是的，所以我们在那届世界杯期间确实做过节目，但我不在现场。所以那是他们真正开始试图向外推广的第一届世界杯，对吧？是的，他们试图把它带到一个——我的意思是，你觉得他们应该这么做吗？传播足球的福音，还是你觉得它应该在那些人们真正关心足球的地方举办？嗯，这是一个好问题。我的意思是，在下一届世界杯上，他们又将与墨西哥和加拿大联合举办。不过，我不介意它在世界各地举办。美国是一个奇怪的地方，你知道的，人们说他们不感兴趣，
and it's not there it's obviously not in their top four sports. So I didn't feel like it was... If I was a player, it wouldn't be the one where I would have wanted to go at that particular point to play, but I'd just kind of finished. So, yeah, whilst it's good that it's global, and I agree with that, I think it's important to be in countries really that do least like football. Well, I mean, there's not being interested in football. And then there's being so obsessed by football that when one of your players scores an own goal, you shoot him. So the most notorious episode in the 94 World Cup in America is when Colombia lose to the United States and get knocked out.
而且它显然不在他们最受欢迎的前四项运动中。所以我不觉得……如果我是球员，在那个特定的时间点，它不会是我想要去踢球的地方，但我当时刚好快要退役了。所以，是的，虽然它走向全球是件好事，我也赞同这一点，但我认为重要的是，赛事确实应该去那些最不喜欢足球的国家。嗯，我的意思是，不感兴趣是一回事。而痴迷到这种程度——当你的某个球员踢进一个乌龙球时，你竟然开枪打死他——又是另一回事。因此，94年美国世界杯上最臭名昭著的插曲，就是哥伦比亚输给美国队并被淘汰出局。
And Andres Escobar scores, he scores an own goal and he gets shot by, what is it, the chauffeur of two meddling gangsters, I think. Yeah. And that's... It's indescribable, isn't it? Yeah. Because the reason why the World Cup matters is that passions are so high. But that must, does that episode kind of hang as a warning to everyone in world football as to just how far it could go?
安德烈斯·埃斯科瓦尔打进了一记乌龙球，然后被……我想是个干预政治的黑帮分子的司机给枪杀了他。是的。这简直……真是难以形容，对吧？是的。因为世界杯之所以重要，是因为大家的情感是如此强烈。但那个插曲，难道没有成为对世界足坛所有人的一个警示，提醒人们事情可能会走向多么极端的恶劣吗？
Well, it shouldn't, obviously. I mean, to do something like that to one of your players for just basically making a mistake. I mean, it's not like he deliberately scored an own goal or anything like that um to one of your players for just basically making a mistake i mean it's not like he deliberately scored an own goal or anything like that but no i mean that's i mean it's a staggering story that that people i mean yes we all care and we get passionate and we want our country to do well in in in sport but in and in football for me in particular but it's just unimaginable that it could lead to something like that a terrible thing he said he this was before he said in football unlike bullfighting there is no death in football no one dies no one gets killed he said that i haven't seen terrible yeah terrible thing to have said but i suppose it's an example isn't it of how
嗯，显然不应该这样。我的意思是，仅仅因为一名球员犯了个错误，就对他们做出这种事。我的意思是，又不是他故意踢进乌龙球什么的……我的意思是，仅仅因为犯了个错误就对球员做出这种事。又不是他故意踢进乌龙球什么的。不，我的意思是，这是一个令人震惊的故事，人们……是的，我们都在乎，我们充满激情，我们希望自己的国家在体育运动中取得好成绩，特别是对我而言在足球运动中，但这种事可能会导致那样的结局，简直是不可想象的。这是一件可怕的事情。他说过，这发生在他说过的话之前：在足球中，不像斗牛，足球里没有死亡，没有人会死，没有人会被杀。他是这么说的。我没见过……是的，太可怕了。这真是一件可怕的话题，但我猜这也是一个例子，说明了……
football there's always a slight sense that football is that people try to create the football is just entertainment and escapism from the world i mean obviously that's why so many of us love football because fat as fans but you can't ever escape it i mean so to go back to your story about that meeting in south africa the 2018 world cup was awarded to russia r, yeah. And by the time, in the intervening period, Russia had taken Crimea and had become involved in eastern Ukraine. And the World Cup happens in Russia. I mean, you went to Russia, didn't you? You went to the Kremlin and did the draw.
足球总是带有一种轻微的感觉，人们试图营造一种氛围，认为足球只是一种娱乐，是逃避现实世界的方式。我的意思是，显然这就是为什么我们这么多人热爱足球，作为球迷而言。但你永远无法真正逃避它。所以，回到你刚才讲的关于南非那次会议的故事，2018年世界杯主办权交给了俄罗斯。而在那期间，俄罗斯占领了克里米亚，并卷入了乌克兰东部的冲突。然后世界杯就在俄罗斯举行了。我的意思是，你去了俄罗斯，对吧？你去了克里米亚……不对，是去了克里姆林宫并主持了抽签仪式。
I did the draw for FIFA at that stage, which was in the Kremlin. It's funny, I was asked to meet Putin a couple of times and refused because of obviously what was going on. And I think it was quite a good decision now. I bet you're glad there's no photos. Yeah, and it was amazing to get behind the scenes in the Kremlin. I was like in a solid gold dressing room. What happens if I press this red button?
我当时确实为国际足联主持了抽签仪式，就在克里姆林宫。说来搞笑，我曾几次被邀请去见普京，但都拒绝了，显然是因为当时正在发生的那些事。现在回想起来，我觉得那是个相当不错的决定。我敢打赌你很庆幸一张照片都没有留下。是的，能够深入克里姆林宫的幕后真是太神奇了。我感觉自己就像在一个纯金的更衣室里。如果我按下这个红色的按钮会发生什么？
Whoops. I know, and it was funny because we had they had um i was hosting it and they had like um eight representatives of the countries that had won the world cup to actually pull the balls out the pot and we rehearsed for three days because it was incredibly complicated the draw because so you know this continent couldn't play against this continent you couldn't play there you had certain amounts um so we had three days rehearsals and when they said three days rehearsal i thought really is that necessary um but it was um and the draw went quite well and diego was maradona was doing the draw he didn't turn up for the
哎呀。我懂，而且很有趣的是，当时我们有……我是主持人，现场有八位曾赢得过世界杯的国家代表来从抽签罐里抽出球。我们排练了三天，因为抽签过程极其复杂。你知道的，这个洲不能和那个洲对阵，你不能和某些队伍分在一组，有各种各样的限制条件。所以我们排练了三天。当他们说排练三天的时候，我还想，真的有这个必要吗？但确实……而且抽签进行得很顺利，迭戈·马拉多纳当时也在参与抽签。他没有来参加排练，
rehearsals he just came at the end because he's diego and um i remember he he drew the first one out and he picked out with his hand and i went, oh, the hand of God strikes again. And he laughed at that. And then it was funny because he came up to me after the draw and it went really well. It went pretty smoothly, thankfully. And he came up to me and he went, Gary, you gave me a big hug. Because obviously I knew because I filmed with him before.
他只是在最后才出现，因为他是迭戈。我记得他抽出了第一个球，用手把球拿了出来，然后我说：“哦，上帝之手再次显灵了。”他听了哈哈大笑。抽签结束后他走到我面前，整个过程非常顺利，谢天谢地。他走过来对我说：“加里，你给了我一个大大的拥抱。”因为显然我认识他，以前跟他拍过节目。
And he said, Gary, he said, you're so good at this. He said, you were quite a good footballer, he said. He said, but if you were as good at football as you are at doing this, he said, you might have been nearly as good as me. Oh, my word. And I looked at him, what a lad. What a lad. But you didn't, so looking back at that now,
他说：“加里，你太擅长这个了。你以前是个挺不错的足球运动员，但如果你做这个的水平跟你踢球的水平一样，那你可能就差点跟我一样优秀了。”噢，我的天哪。我看着他，真是个妙人。真是一个妙人。但你没有，所以现在回过头来看，
do you think the World Cup shouldn't have gone to Russia in 2018? I mean, Russia is a good footballing country and it's just, you know, now do you think the world cup shouldn't have gone to to russia in 2018 i mean i mean russia is a good footballing country and it's just you know and and and often you know but we hate their politics and hate their leadership and and and we obviously hate what's happened subsequently i mean it's i was more worried about the qatar one because that was um obviously bought um yeah um but the you know But the Russian one was a reasonable bid, but I thought our bid was much stronger.
你觉得2018年世界杯不应该交给俄罗斯吗？我的意思是，俄罗斯是一个足球强国，而且……你懂的，现在你觉得2018年世界杯不应该交给俄罗斯吗？我的意思是，俄罗斯是一个足球强国，而且……你懂的，通常情况下，虽然我们讨厌他们的政治，讨厌他们的领导层，而且我们显然讨厌后来发生的事情。我的意思是，我当时其实更担心卡塔尔那届，因为那一届显然是买来的。但俄罗斯的那次申办还算合理，不过我觉得我们的申办更有力。
And I'm sure there's been no evidence of corruption and particularly on the Russian one. I mean, basically everybody does bribes in a World Cup bid. It's changed a little bit now.
而且我确信没有证据表明存在腐败，尤其是俄罗斯的那一次。我的意思是，基本上每个人在申办世界杯时都会行贿。现在情况稍微有点改变了。
Well, you know, those cats don't get housed. Well, that's it. You can't do that. I know. So, I mean, but no, I don't think, I mean, the World Cup actually in Russia was really good. And the place was sanitized and it was, you know, everything was, everyone was looked after properly.
好吧，你知道的，现在那些家伙没地方藏身了。就是这样。你不能再那样做了。我懂。所以，我的意思是，不，我不认为……世界杯在俄罗斯举办其实真的很好。那个地方被整顿得很干净，一切都井井有条，每个人都得到了妥善的照顾。
But for the people of Russia, I would say, yes, it was nice, great for them to have the world cup and that they really enjoyed it politically though i mean there are so many instances in in the history of of the world cup where you could go politically we shouldn't really have had it there you know you talked i remember you had the 1934 world cup with with um the backdrop of mussolini wanting it to support fascism and things like that. So, um,
但对于俄罗斯人民来说，我会说，是的，挺好的，举办世界杯对他们来说很棒，他们真的很享受。不过从政治角度来看，我的意思是，在世界杯的历史上有那么多例子，从政治角度来看，我们其实不应该把比赛放在那些地方。你刚才提到过，我记得1934年世界杯的背景是墨索里尼想要借此支持法西斯主义之类的事情。所以，
we've had lots, 78 in Argentina, the military junta there was awful. Yeah. Cause I don't think that that's any, you know, better than, than Qatar getting it.
我们经历过很多次，78年的阿根廷世界杯，那里的军政府简直糟透了。是的。因为我不认为那比卡塔尔获得主办权要好到哪里去。
No, no, that's my point. It's, there's always something 2014 in Brazil, there are massive demonstrations on the streets for people saying, why are we investing in stadia when we should be investing in social care?
不，不，这就是我的观点。总会有这样那样的问题。2014年在巴西，街头爆发了大规模游行，人们抗议道：“为什么我们要投资建设体育场，而不是把钱花在社会福利上？”
So they took to the streets. And so I'm kind of experienced with that. So it's, but at the same time, looking at Qatar, that's, you know, that whole thing was bought just just to play devil's advocate so they've the world cup's been held in japan and south korea yeah in um in 2002 so that was asia's first world cup and it was held in south africa so that was africa's world first world cup qatar is the first muslim country to host it. And so if it's a genuinely World Cup, isn't there a case for saying that it should go to regions of the world
于是他们走上了街头。所以我对这种情况多少有些经验。所以，与此同时，看看卡塔尔，那整个事情全都是买下来的……为了扮演一下反面角色，世界杯也曾在日本和韩国举办过，是的，在2002年，那是亚洲的第一届世界杯；它还在南非举办过，那是非洲的第一届世界杯。卡塔尔是第一个举办世界杯的穆斯林国家。所以，如果这是一届真正的世界世界杯，难道没有理由认为它应该去往那些既不是南美也不是欧洲的地区吗？
that are not South America or Europe? No, I absolutely agree with that. I think, but, you know, you could have had something in a Middle Eastern World Cup. There's no, but I think the issue obviously is, you know, there's human rights issues. There's issues around every World Cup, wherever is we all we always have this build up but the at the minute there's this whole sport washing concept where you know people try and get respect because they kind of buy it through sport um you know we've we've had lots of meetings about this
不，我完全同意这一点。我认为，但是，你知道的，你本可以在中东举办一届世界杯。没有……但我认为问题显然在于，存在人权问题。每一届世界杯都会伴随着各种问题，无论在哪里举办。我们总是会经历这样的舆论预热，但目前存在着整个“体育洗白”的概念，即人们试图通过体育来购买并获得尊重。我们为此开过很多次会，
going into this world cup and how we cover it and how we do this and that. And we had meetings with Amnesty International. And they said, sport washing works if you stop talking about the issues. So we'll keep raising the issues. But do I think it should be there? No. Did I think it should be in Russia? No. But, you know, how many countries in the world?
探讨我们如何看待这届世界杯，如何进行报道，以及如何处理这些事情。我们与国际特赦组织开了会。他们说：“体育洗白只有在你停止谈论问题时才会奏效。”所以我们会继续提出这些问题。但我觉得它应该在那里举办吗？不。我觉得它应该在俄罗斯举办吗？不。但是，世界上有多少国家？
Obviously, there are different levels of human rights issues and whether you've invaded someone and stuff like this, but you'd probably limit yourself quite drastically if you wanted everyone to be holier than thou. But that's not saying that there are different levels of human rights issues. And what about this issue? So the first, you talked about 1970. So that's a World Cup of 16 teams, and it's about this issue so you know the first you talked about 1970 so that's a world cup of 16 teams and it's quite a simple structure the world cup's now 32 i think yeah
显然，人权问题存在着不同的严重程度，比如你是否侵略了别人之类的事情，但如果你要求每个国家都必须是道德圣人，那你可能会大大限制自己的选择。但这并不是说人权问题没有程度之分。那么这个问题呢？你刚才提到了1970年。那是只有16支球队的世界杯，结构非常简单。现在的世界杯有32支球队，我想是的，
and it's going to be about 700 isn't it yeah it's ever more 48 the next one it's ever more kind of baroque and it kind of and there is a definite sense now maybe you some people listening to this will say oh these are just like old men moaning. But there's a definite sense, I would say, never, never, that the specialness has already rather been lost. There are a lot of matches that don't matter, that there are a lot of teams that turn up for two weeks and then go home, that it's bigger and bloated and therefore has lost some of the magic that it had.
以后会变成大概700支球队，对吧？是的，下一届将扩军到48支。它变得越来越庞大繁复，而且现在有一种绝对的感觉——也许听节目的某些人会说：“哦，这不过是几个老头在发牢骚。”但我可以说，这种“特殊感已经开始消逝”的感觉是前所未有的强烈。有太多无关紧要的比赛，有太多球队来这里待两周就打包回家了。赛事变得越来越大、越来越臃肿，因此失去了一些原本具有的魔力。
I disagree to a degree on that. I don't think there are many meaningless matches because obviously you've got the group stage unless you win your first two games. I mean, you will get games in the last stage of that group that are fairly meaningless. I watched with Tom in 2006. We went to the pub and we watched Ukraine versus Saudi Arabia.
我在某种程度上并不同意这种说法。我不认为有很多毫无意义的比赛，因为显然你有小组赛，除非你前两场都赢了。我的意思是，你在小组赛的最后阶段确实会看到一些意义不大的比赛。2006年我和汤姆一起看的。我们去了酒吧，观看了乌克兰对阵沙特阿拉伯的比赛。
Yeah. I remember that. Yeah. Good for you. Nil-nil. Nil-nil, Gary. Nil-nil thriller.
是的，我记得。真为你高兴。0比0。0比0，加里。一场0比0的惊天大战。
I can assure you that was a meaningless match. No, you will get meaningless games and obviously occasionally, but once you reach the knockout stage of the last 16, then it's, it's, it's all wonderfully exciting though. I think the,
我向你保证，那绝对是一场毫无意义的比赛。不，你确实会看到毫无意义的比赛，偶尔确实如此。但一旦进入16强淘汰赛阶段，那就……一切都变得妙趣横生、令人兴奋了。我认为，
I've been in the football in some of the world that, you know, in the last world cup,'s it's it's all wonderfully exciting though i think the i've been the football in some of the world that you know in the last world cup we had some fantastic football matches some brilliant games um and you know football i think is better than it's the actual sport itself is better than it's ever been because of some good law changes and you can't just kick people everywhere now the playing surfaces beautiful, which make for better football. We've got some wonderfully gifted footballers right around the world. Politically, obviously there are issues, massive issues, which we've talked about.
我在世界上的一些地方参与过足球……你知道的，在上一届世界杯上，我们有一些非常精彩的足球比赛，一些极棒的较量。而且你知道，我认为足球现在比以往任何时候都要好，这项运动本身比以往任何时候都好，这得益于一些出色的规则修改，你不能再随心所欲地到处铲人犯规了。球场草坪美观极了，这让比赛变得更好。我们在世界各地拥有一些天赋异禀的足球运动员。从政治角度来看，显然存在问题，非常严重的问题，我们已经讨论过了。
But football-wise, I think it's a World Cup. So to give more people, more countries the chance to play in it, you can't imagine how massive that is for a small nation to be suddenly playing in the world cup i i read i was reading about the um south korea who when they helped stage the world semi-final they got to the semi-finals and the south korean president said of that that it was korea's happiest day since dan gunn who was the son of a bear and the creator of acupuncture, founded the country in 2333 BC. Great. Hang on a minute. Hang on a minute.
但从足球角度来看，我认为这是一届世界杯。因此，为了给更多的人、更多的国家提供参与的机会，你无法想象对于一个小国家来说，突然能够参加世界杯意味着多么巨大的意义。我读过关于……南非……不对，是韩国。当他们协助举办世界杯时，他们闯入了半决赛，韩国总统对此评价说，这是自檀君——也就是熊的儿子、针灸术的创始人，于公元前2333年建国以来，韩国最快乐的一天。太棒了。等等。等一下。
He was the son of a bear. Apparently, yes. That's amazing. We sometimes have facts on this podcast, Gary, that turn out to be quite true. Not necessarily true. That may well be one of them. But just to end, the justification for doing the World Cup on a history podcast is that it holds a mirror up to changing patterns in geopolitics. And I guess that one thing you could say about Qatar hosting it is that it is doing that. I mean, it is inconceivable that in, I don't know, 1990 or let alone kind of 1950, that Qatar would ever stage it.
他是熊的儿子？根据记载，是的。太惊人了。加里，我们这个播客有时会爆出一些事实，结果证明它们相当真实。不一定全是真的。那可能就是其中之一。但最后，在历史播客中谈论世界杯的理由是，它像一面镜子，映射出地缘政治不断变化的格局。我想，关于卡塔尔举办世界杯，你可以说的一点是，它确实做到了这一点。我的意思是，在——我不知道——1990年，更不用说1950年了，卡塔尔举办世界杯是不可想象的。
And in a way, it's reflective of the kind of shifts in global power, global wealth, all kinds of things like that. I think it's a reflection of that, isn't it? There's no question about that. I mean, it wouldn't, as you say, 30, probably even 20 years ago, it wouldn't have been thought of. But 12 years ago, it was't have been thought of but it well 12 years ago it was decided it was going to be there
从某种意义上说，它反映了全球权力、全球财富等各种事物的转变。我认为这是这种转变的反映，对吧？这是毫无疑问的。我的意思是，正如你所说，在30年前、甚至可能是20年前，人们都不会想到这一点。但在12年前，它就已经被决定了……
to the shock of the world but it is there and obviously it's a very very important part of the world now incredibly wealthy Qatari's own
震惊了全世界，但它确实在那里举办了。显然，这是当今世界非常非常重要的一个部分，极其富有的卡塔尔人拥有……
well most of London don't they as well and they've got a lot of gas and they've got a lot of gas and so that's where it is because money talks doesn't it right and it always will so in other words 20 years time whether you like it or not people will be the world cup will be somewhere else the people are
嗯，几乎买下了半个伦敦，对吧？而且他们拥有大量的天然气，拥有大量的天然气。所以事情就是这样，因为金钱能主导一切，对吧？而且永远都会如此。换句话说，20年以后，不管你喜欢与否，世界杯将会去到别的地方，人们会……
i mean presumably a chinese world cup within the next 20 30 years that's the other question i want to just what is is that if it's a world cup two massive countries are missing from the World Cup, China and India. So I think India did qualify, didn't they, for one World Cup, and they weren't allowed to play barefoot, so they refused to turn up. Yeah, I think that's a slight myth, but they didn't turn up. I think that sounds a bit like a myth. They didn't turn up. It's like the son of a bear kind of myth, that one, isn't it?
我的意思是，大概在未来20到30年内中国会举办世界杯吧？这是我想问的另一个问题，那就是……如果这是一届世界杯，两个人口大国却缺席了世界杯——中国和印度。所以我想印度确实曾获得过一次世界杯资格，但他们不允许赤脚踢球，于是他们拒绝参赛。是的，我觉得那有点像个传说，但他们确实没去。我觉得这听起来有点像个传说。他们没有去。这就跟“熊的儿子”那个传说差不多，对吧？
So can it really be a World Cup without, say, China and India? Well, there's qualifying. So they go through that stage. So pretty much every country in the world takes part in the, pretty much, I think, in the qualifying. So they have been part of the World Cup process. I mean, China have played in World Cups, obviously. And, you know, it's not probably their
所以，如果没有中国和印度这样的国家参加，这真的能算是一届世界杯吗？嗯，有预选赛。所以他们要经历那个阶段。基本上世界上每个国家都参与了……差不多每个国家，我认为，都参加了预选赛。所以他们一直是世界杯进程的一部分。我的意思是，中国显然也踢过世界杯。而且，你知道的，这可能不是他们的……
biggest sport, but it's growing. In India, it's starting to grow as well, to a degree. Yeah, so time will tell. But they're obviously countries that are not as interested in football as elsewhere. But it's probably the most global sport, certainly team sport, really. So Gary, this has been brilliant. It's strange to think that if your career turned out differently, we'd have been doing this podcast with Mark Haley. But thank heavens he left Mark Haley out and kept me in the side. So,
最大的运动，但它还在增长。在印度，它也开始有了一定程度的增长。是的，所以时间会证明一切。但很显然，这些国家对足球的兴趣不如其他地方。不过，这或许是最全球化的运动，绝对是团队运动。加里，这次访谈太棒了。很难想象，如果你的职业生涯有所不同，我们现在就会和马克·黑利一起做这个播客了。谢天谢地，他把马克·黑利漏掉了，把我留在了队里。所以，
so we've just had to make do with you. I'm terribly sorry. How can I apologize? Before we let you go, it would be remiss not to ask you for a few special predictions for Restless History listeners. So first of all, the finalists. The finalists in this World Cup coming up?
所以我们只能将就你了。实在是非常抱歉。我该怎么道歉呢？在我们放你走之前，不向你询问一些给“历史余音”听众的特别预测就太失职了。首先，决赛队伍。这次即将到来的世界杯的决赛队伍是谁？
Yeah. It's really open, this one. I think there's no obvious... It's also a World Cup like we've never had before. It's unique. It's in the middle of a domestic lead season, certainly in Europe and a lot of other countries. We've never had a Winter World Cup,
是的。这次真的很难说。我觉得没有什么明显的……这也是一届前所未有的世界杯。它是独一无二的。它在欧洲以及许多其他国家的国内联赛赛季中期举行。我们从未有过冬季世界杯，
Northern Hemisphere Winter World Cup. So it's going to be difficult. And there's lots of players who are getting injured. I would have probably tipped France, but they've lost Kante, they've lost Varane, they've lost Pogba. Other countries have lost big players too. I suspect we might get a South American winner. It's been 20 years since we did,
北半球的冬季世界杯。所以这将很艰难。而且有很多球员受伤。我原本可能会看好法国，但他们失去了坎特、瓦拉内、博格巴。其他国家也失去了重要球员。我猜我们可能会迎来一个南美冠军。距离我们上次夺冠已经过去20年了，
since Brazil won in Japan-Korea. So, Argentina have not lost a game for around three and a half years. Brazil, always,
自从巴西在日韩夺冠以来。所以，阿根廷已经大约三年半没有输过球了。巴西，一直，
always strong. The European teams, England have a chance. We do have a chance. It's a little bit lighter than central defence. Germany always have a chance. It's a little bit lighter than central defence. Germany always have a chance because they're German.
一直都很强。欧洲球队中，英格兰有机会。我们确实有机会。中后卫稍微薄弱了一点。德国一直有机会。中后卫稍微薄弱了一点。德国一直有机会，因为他们是德国队。
But they've not really got a striker, but France have won it in the past. France could easily still win it or they could implode. Spain have got a chance, but they're a bit young and not great up front. So I actually, if I had to say, I'd probably go either Brazil or Argentina. And would you like to see Lionel Messi?
但他们并没有真正的前锋，不过法国过去曾赢得过冠军。法国完全有可能再次夺冠，或者也可能彻底崩盘。西班牙有机会，但他们有点年轻，锋线不算太强。所以实际上，如果非要我说，我可能会选择巴西或阿根廷。你希望看到莱昂内尔·梅西吗？
So Messi for those, I mean, surely everyone knows who Messi is. I would hope so. Certainly the most, arguably the most talented player who's ever lived. Yeah. I never thought I'd see a better player than Diego Maradona. I'm not saying Messi is a better player than Maradona, but I never thought anyone would compare. And they're so similar.
所以关于梅西，我的意思是，Surely（当然）每个人都知道梅西是谁。我希望如此。这绝对是、可以说是有史以来最有天赋的球员。是的。我从没想过能看到比迭戈·马拉多纳更好的球员。我不是说梅西比马拉多纳更好，但我从没想过有人能相提并论。而且他们太相似了。
And if I had to choose, I'd probably give it Messi because of longevity of career. Obviously, Maradona had his issues which affected his career and Messi never has. If England don't win it or don't get to the final,
如果我必须选择，我可能会把票投给梅西，因为他的职业生涯足够长。显然，马拉多纳有他影响职业生涯的问题，而梅西从来没有。如果英格兰没有夺冠或者没有进入决赛，
I would love to see Messi do it for Argentina. It's pretty much the only trophy he's not won. Yeah. And he's won this Copa America. He did that not 18 months ago, which was amazing for him because he'd lost in three, four major finals.
我很想看到梅西为阿根廷赢得冠军。这几乎是他唯一没有拿过的奖杯了。是的，他赢得了美洲杯。那是在18个月前，对他来说太棒了，因为他之前在三、四场重要决赛中失利过。
But he's an unbelievable player. For me, he's just joyous to watch. So the rest is football predictions yeah i'm useless at predicting anything no but i like the fact we've done we've done three episodes on the history of the world cup and we've ended up with predictions uh and now we can see whether they come true or not there you go so thank you so much for coming on. Thank you. Absolute pleasure. Thanks everyone for listening. And we have coming up 32 episodes, not about football, but about aspects of the history
但他是一个不可思议的球员。对我来说，看他踢球就是一种享受。所以“足球的其余部分”预测，是的，我对预测任何事都一窍不通。不，但我喜欢我们做了三集关于世界杯历史的节目，最后以预测结束，嗯，现在我们可以看看它们是否会成真了。就是这样，非常感谢你来参加。谢谢。绝对是我的荣幸。谢谢大家的收听。接下来我们将有32集节目，不是关于足球，而是关于每一个参赛国家的历史
of every single country that is playing. Every country in the World Cup, we do its history in the next 32 episodes, Gary. Hats off to you guys. One a day. One a day. I'll be listening. I'll be listening.
世界杯上的每一个国家，我们在接下来的32集里讲它的历史，加里。向你们致敬。一天一集。一天一集。我会听的。我会听的。
It'll give me a lot of good lines for my World Cup, hopefully, when I'm presenting. When we come back to you in 32 days' time and we say, Gary, tell us about the Costa Rican Civil War, you will be enormously well-informed. Do you not think I already know everything about that? Yeah.
希望当我进行主持时，它能为我的世界杯提供很多精彩的台词。当我们在32天后再次找你，对你说“加里，给我们讲讲哥斯达黎加内战吧”，你一定会见多识广。难道你不认为我已经对那一切了如指掌了吗？是的。
Great. We should have had a talk about that. Don't test me. All right. Bye-bye, everybody. Bye-bye. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
太好了。我们应该聊聊这个。别考我。好了，大家再见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》。这里有你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一剂八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想无广告收听、收看独家节目并提前获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂时还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。